foreign
well in the uh Twilight uh the in as
2022 is coming to a close uh Congress
passed a
massive spending bill of course
um because that's what you should do if
you're in Congress and uh but a good the
good news is as a part of that they also
passed what is appropriately called the
secure
Act of 2022 2.0
so what is the secure act 2.0 well it
changes a bunch of things in your
retirement and a couple of things in
your student loans as well and a good
blog at ramseysolutions.com right now
very good detail on this unpacked uh if
you want to get in there and really look
at it and plug around I think we post
those blogs on Facebook too if I
remember James and uh but George I want
to take a minute since that blog's out
there and you guys can go through it all
and and look at it in detail but for
those of you that don't make it over the
blog let's hit the highlights yeah
there's a ton in here that really help a
lot of people with their retirement I
mean it's secure act stands for setting
every Community up for retirement
enhancement so kudos to the marketing
team that got to create that little
acronym there yeah well good luck with
that part but anyway it's good it's good
updates it's some things that needed to
happen yeah so it's starting with
required minimum distributions you'll
hear these called rmds the age is rising
to 73 instead of 72 which means you have
an extra year without the government
tapping you to get some of their cash
yeah it required minimum distributions
are your 401k your Roth or your not Roth
your traditional IRAs they require you
to start taking money out at a minimum
schedule so they can tax it and it used
to be 70 and a half then it moved to 72
and with this it moves to 73. so you can
leave your money alone and not touch it
until 73 now that's good next one no
more required minimum distributions from
Roth 401ks and Roth 403bs so this one's
interesting because you've already paid
the taxes on it so they're saying you've
already paid the taxes you can just have
it it doesn't do anything to force you
to start taking it out on rmds so we're
going to let you just let it sit there
and grow tax-free another reason to love
a Roth that's great next up smaller
penalties for missed required minimum
distributions it was 50 it's coming down
to 25 percent now if you miss your rmds
no that's good uh next higher catch-up
contributions on the way so if you're
year 50 years or older there's a lot of
great ways you can step up your
retirement you know put an extra
thousand in your IRA for example an
extra five thousand extra 7 500 in your
401ks and they're increasing that yeah
60 to 63 beginning in 25 not in 2025
January 1 if you're aged 6 to 6 60 to 63
you'll be able to put ten thousand
dollars annually into a workplace
retirement plan an additional ten
thousand dollars and so it allows you if
you're quote running behind is it too
late for me this is for you right love
it all right next up on the good news
front easier access to retirement funds
for emergencies nor is it not good news
that's one of the downers of this plan
here we were doing so great Dave we're
on a great about a thousand until we got
to stupid land and so here's what this
means uh starting in 2024 you can
withdraw up to a thousand dollars from
your retirement account for personal or
family emergencies if you've been
listening to the show for more than uh
10 seconds you'll know that you you
should never tap your retirement
accounts for emergencies yeah you should
have an emergency fund and leave your
freaking retirement account alone and
let it grow and make you rich absolutely
all right
here's an interesting one curious to get
your take on this Dave employers must
automatically enroll you into a
workplace retirement plan
this is Nanny State stuff holding your
hand this is uh we're going to take care
of you because you're too stupid to take
care of yourself idea and so now when
you join a company that has a 401k the
company is required to sign you up for
the 401K automatically at an automatic
minimum contribution rate of three
percent and if you don't want that to
happen you have to opt out manually go
in and opt out you have to stop it from
occurring uh say that's too much control
it's got a good intent I want everybody
to have a retirement account that's a
good thing yes you need to be in your
401k but let's say you're working the
baby steps you would need to opt out but
if you're not doing 401K because you're
on baby step two well and the other
problem is if you are in a place to
invest you've got three percent you
don't realize it you need to up that to
15 if you're out of debt with a fully
funded emergency fund yeah so be sure
you pay attention don't don't you know
we're from the government and we're here
to help these are scary words okay yeah
three percent rate is not going to get
you very far in retirement so we've got
to do better for sure next this has been
one of some hot debate employers can
match your student loan payments with
retirement contributions
it's confusing yes so it sounds like
they're paying your student loans now
some employers are now offering a
benefit that has nothing to do with this
just where they will help you pay your
student loans off one way or another
whatever it is they'll give you they'll
match you they'll do whatever it has
nothing to do with anything as far as
this stuff goes this
is not that this is you pay up to three
thousand dollars on your student loan
and your employer puts up to three
thousand dollars into your 401k
which doesn't it's just like wouldn't
that incentivize you to never pay off
your student loans we want you to eat
apples so we're going to chop oranges
it's just weird it's it you mix these
things up and and people are getting
confused about already they think it
means the government's going to pay part
of your student or the employer is going
to pay part of your student loan and
match you on what you're putting on your
student loan they're not they have to
put it in the 401K so it's weird it's
because anything that gets more money
against your student loan or causes you
to do that anything that gets more money
into your retirement I'm for all of that
but this is just convoluted and weird
well wouldn't you be pissed if you
already paid off your student loans or
didn't have any and Joe schmo's next to
you is getting an extra three grand in
his 401k that's a benefit though that's
your employer offering a benefit the
employer is not required to offer this
benefit I'm curious to see how many
employers do this yeah I don't think
they'll well you never know you never
know out there all right next up you can
roll over unused 529 plan funds to a
Roth IRA ding ding this one's good this
one I love because that's been a big you
know point of objection people go well
Dave what if my kid doesn't go to
college they don't use all the money
that money is just wasted yeah it's not
you can now after 15 years your kid head
rolls it into their Roth IRA no
penalties up to the annual contribution
so you put a hundred thousand hundred
fifty thousand bucks into a uh 529 uh
kid uses 75 or 80 000 of it whatever's
left in there sits there 15 years
growing tax-free in good mutual funds
and then they roll it into a Roth IRA
into good mutual funds and it continues
to grow tax-free no penalties that one
I'm a huge fan of I love this one this
is a fun one too Roth options are now
available for simple IRAs and sep IRAs
so folks that are self-employed business
owners this is cool I'm confused I
thought that was already there
yeah I'm not sure they didn't already
have that but I could be wrong so it's
good though yeah the simple IRA is
simply a 401k for small business uh and
the SEP IRA is a uh the simpler the
simple incentive match plan for it's
it's best used by a uh a solopreneur
because if you have employees you have
to put the same amount in you got to put
it for yourself so we'd seldom use
Sapphire as much but simple hours are
great for small businesses to open up
and now they can do a Roth that's good
news and lastly new emergency savings
account option alongside retirement
accounts so this one's a little
different than the previous one
um but it's saying that the employer can
set aside up to 2500 annually for
non-highly compensated employees in a
separate emergency savings alongside
their retirement account so it's a
little sidecar here yeah but is it
invested the problem is it's 2500 is not
enough for an emergency fund and so then
you've got the Thousand you can take out
of your 401k for your emergency and
you've got it all over at the employer
and so people get the idea oh my
emergency fund's taken care of it's not
it's not enough money there's very few
of you that three to six months of
expenses represents 2500 bucks so this
is a this is one of those head fakes
that the government's saying hey look we
did something and you didn't want to do
anything because it's not it's not
sufficient to cover it now they could do
up to ten thousand dollars in there or
something that might cover some people's
you know emergency not enough to to do
any damage I wouldn't use this instead
of your emergency phone and I wouldn't
use the option to cash money out of your
401k for emergencies either as your
emergency fund I wouldn't do either one
I'd leave all of that alone well credit
where credits do there's a lot of wins
in here and you guys can check out the
entire article we've got it linked in
the show notes wherever you're listening
of course at ramseysolutions.com but I
need her to win today I'm gonna call
this a win I'm gonna call it a win we
pick on and we can even allow uh
President Joe Biden to call a win he
signed it I'm sure he's already tweeted
it he signed it and so he gets a win on
that way to go President Biden you don't
hear that often from Dave not not at
often at all can't shoot down a balloon
but choose to sign this this is the
Ramsay show